[Music]
pigfuckers pocket there's another
this left hand exposing the ball and the
finish
dream on
[Music]
watch Kevin Durant here is it the Milky
Way too for everybody to try to find
their own men yeah absolutely as a rim
runner the Rudy Gobert Washington state
small gym Wizards scored five straight
points to force a
foul on the play I want to see them
really defendants own peers
the Warriors open it up with their
largest lead and Kevin Durant's come on
right there living room Newark is back
for the rebound this to the middle push
to the middle
[Applause]
[Music]
reflected again another state to are
more it's candy me get down chemical
taking itself
[Applause]
- banner it's know how to make to play
work things I ran off the good defense
chosen out Iguodala said I'll give it up
to you
does you have an angle
you think Durant has been frustrated and
cyber thing with his team they only
average two more shots as you see Durant
get the easy dunk right there but they
placed so much more fluid because when
steps on the court he plays with the
faster pace than dirt we did not know he
was guarding that player able to whip by
siakam off the dribble and Durant with
40 for the night
and they're down by just 2 he was
thinking score first that was the the
problem beautiful lob Deacon Dallas at
Durant on the baseline that is
incredibly well thrown with two for one
situation potentially Durant goes around
the world and punches it home
over at vodka this former OKC teammate
and that had to get enough time to
recover from a limitation on the shot
clock at one
KD able to dunk it with the left hand
you don't need a three but you need a
store rats hammering
I've been Durant drop throwing on Newark
itches head
Steve pearl with telling 3d turns with a
full head of steam down that page one
that's the second ball movement man move
it wow what a beautiful pass by Tremont
green watch this pass by draymond Green
he's been assisting more with fewer
turnovers and that's the zone good
defensive play here comes curry Perry
down the middle alley-oop to Durant
beautiful fast-break and I go look sit
back with exertion the basketball and
making you pay the price on the
offensive end I'll stand in deliberate
slice averaging six assists a game they
could do even more or a dose of tripled
off his heel Hey now they're giving the
one that we've seen over this pin game
stretch and Nate McMillan forced to call
a timeout
Antonio neo then up in my craw know the
lobs if they're rancid Iguodala finding
in a few more minutes pass knocked away
we'll push ahead to Durant's he went to
throw it back to Jordan battle it
ricochets around and Durant got the dung
when he was fouled
ooh and he hit the floor very hard and
then this one looked like it was
turnover all the way but careened off
the heels
both Harrison's Butler can be free
agents in the offseason Eubanks comes in
can't catch that one right at the head
of the pack aside
Durant direct Cole saves it to Iguodala
Durant
[Applause]
it's interesting everyone wants to talk
about draymond Green shooting is down
this year
[Music]
fetish his soul invaluable effective
he's been his cousin's nots in a way of
great
this person came on 24 percent for the
three-point line this season
[Applause]
go to now no he got his mouth
chasing down a long rebound and giving
them extra possessions there's a lot
that Duran nice pass by draymond Green
don't see Miller to the point on a great
one at that Durant that Thompson back to
ke D for the slab great teamwork on the
fast break
[Applause]
and a turnover by the Blazers here's
Thompson passes it to direct but a slam
and klay Thompson is tied his
career-high four assists with the bucket
obviously team Yanis have the thigh free
throw split first lead has been as high
as six sitting on four right now granted
the crossover
family came face-to-face actually
internationally Bob Jim Carrey's Burke
with you at Oracle sounds keeping the
warriors all guys didn't you work them
you may fall in love with one of them
Lozano Williams is pretty cut number one
hasn't now Durant with a slam in a file
DeRozan back cutting incredibly pinpoint
pass and a small one
there's no kick with you didn't have a
guaranteed contract
[Music]
once again I'm gonna predict Durant will
not take a shot to list the game he
continues the best shooting night of his
career they may be perfect the stink
they took the super plays a lot of
[Applause]
lachchi take it to another gear right
there gets around the corner that
commercial break change the right shoe
so now he's wearing two separate shoes
oh the red throws it down
exclamation point is play good execution
at Durant turned a corner
to the thick of the Clippers defense in
an emphatic jam and a technical foul is
going to be called I believe on Beverly
for continuing the conversation are they
going to call double tip illness
[Applause]
choose over 40% around 40% of
three-pointers just got to let it fly
and live with the result with the
[ __ ] five years and they have been
brilliant
here at how beautiful the power for the
Clippers to michael queen who just
checked in thunders free to go in the
fourth
Durant played by hell to ran on a
crossover for what is why is so hard to
stop five four seven tenth from 11 from
the free-throw line
I know he's still able to finish in
traffic that was an oppressive shot
Durant bow and one
and the crowd feeling the same way they
thought there were plenty of contact a
twin does not at this end screen nice
speed to Durant
beautiful assist from draymond Green is
fit to the game and it's back to eight
[Applause]
we swapped it over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the bow
[Applause]
Oh
from Kady again how does he find this
angle I don't know move out the way get
dumped throw a little Williams allowing
the to demand blocked by Thompson the
demand with Lou Williams
and Harold coming into the game and
Durant racing down a floor on another
pretty fee from draymond Green and he'd
been shooting really well late in the
season and 49% the first round
Durant to the basket warriors plus eight
on the boards Durant gets erotic start
and side what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content